this beginner's devops course is your
first step toward a devops engineering
role
it is taught by the ceo and co-founder
of layer ci
the goal of this course will be for
regular developers
and regular engineering practitioners to
learn fundamental devops concepts so
that they can go towards a devops
engineering role
we'll also be talking about devops
broadly in the introduction but beyond
that we'll primarily be talking about
the engineering side of things
[Music]
devops is a methodology that helps
engineering teams
build products better by continuously
integrating user feedback
and if you google devops and you look
for pictures
you'll often see ones like this it
really helps understand how devops is
different than the traditional way of
thinking about software development
back in the day software was developed
much like things would be developed in a
factory
so any input would be programming and
then the output you'd have a product
that you could put on a cd
and you'd sell it to users but since the
advent of the internet
and of continuously updatable software
it's become really easy to launch things
and get user feedback and integrate that
into the current product instead of
making a new version of the product
so websites like facebook continuously
upgrade instead of requiring you to buy
you know a new version of facebook
unlike you know old games like simcity
would require you to buy
a new version of some city and that idea
is really formalized by devops
the sections are planning where you take
a set of features that you want to build
and you work with your team to
make some specifications for what those
features might look like
you code them so developers on your team
will build out these features so that
they can be
released and of course they're built
so for a website you might take the
source code and bundle it into
a javascript that a user's browser could
run for a video game you might make
releases for various different versions
that run on linux and versions that run
on windows and versions that run in the
browser
so you take these built artifacts and
you test them
so testing is both automatic and manual
automatic testing is usually
colloquially known as continuous
integration
and manual testing is colloquially known
as quality
assurance qa and then after it's tested
and you know the stakeholders have all
given their feedback
it's released and continuous deployment
strategies
releasing and deploying all happens
automatically after a change is
known to be good there's a lot of
automation that can be done here in
larger teams
there's you know popular tools like
spinnaker by netflix that we'll
talk about in later talks but the core
idea is you want to take the software
and you want to send it to your users in
a way that they don't notice if there's
problems
so if there's an experimental ui change
you might show it to a few percentage of
users
and get their feedback before you show
it broadly again a company like facebook
which has billions of users
even if one percent of their users
complain they'll get hundreds of
millions of emails
the release is built and deployed so
deploying means it's released to your
users for a website it would mean it's
publicly accessible on the internet for
a cd-rom
you know you'd bundle your things onto a
cd and you distribute that
for a mobile release you'd uh build the
artifact and you'd submit it to the app
store and then the app store would
review it and then publish a new update
that your users could download
and then you operate it operating is
primarily things like scaling
making sure that enough resources exist
for the load adding more servers as
required
configuring things dealing with
architectural problems
essentially and monitoring so as your
users use your software and especially
as they submit things and
start jobs and create posts on your
forms you want to make sure that those
posts are all healthy
and then finally you take all of this
feedback and you put it back to the
planning stage
so the planning stage takes all of the
user feedback takes all of the things
that the
operations and deployments teams learned
about deploying and scaling the product
and then use that to build out new
features solve bugs
and make new versions of the back end
and new versions of the architecture
and then it just continues in the cycle
and this is what people mean when they
say
our company uses devops or our company
is a tech forward or a company is
digitally transformed they they mean
that instead of taking a set of
requirements and building one artifact
which is then shipped
it's a continuous cycle of taking
feedback you know in these two-week
scrum cycles
usually and producing software that
users actually want to use that they've
had some say
in producing devops engineering is
another
common part of devops so beyond just the
methodology which is something that
maybe the technical leaders and ceo
would care about
there's a subfield of devops engineering
and this is usually what engineers mean
when they say devops
and that's usually what job postings
mean when they say devops so if a job
posting is asking for a devops engineer
you know they're not asking for someone
that can plan and deploy and
code they're mostly asking for someone
that can build test release
deploy and monitor
so the three pillars of devops
engineering
are pull request automation deployment
automation
and application performance management
and we'll get into
specifics about those but the idea is
pull request automation
helps developers build things faster and
helps them
understand whether their proposed change
is good faster
deployment automation helps you deploy
your code in a way that users don't
complain
again facebook has lots of deployment
automation because if they
just threw their code out into the void
every time a developer made a change
there'd be hundreds of millions of
complaints and application performance
management
is automation around making sure that
things are healthy so automatically
detecting downtime
automatically waking someone up if you
know the site goes down overnight
automatically rolling back things if
there's a problem and we'll get into the
specifics of all these in future talks
the first pillar which i mentioned was
pull request automation
has primarily to do with the developer
feedback cycle
so developers share work with each other
by proposing
these atomic sets of changes called pull
requests and by atomic i mean
they're a full feature on their own they
don't require other things to run
first it's like if a developer proposes
a pull request
they should be expecting that that
change is good and as far as they can
tell the change fulfills some business
requirement
and then what they have to do is get
through some gates
so organizations and pull request
automation
their goal is to make sure that
developers can tell very quickly whether
their change is good or not
so for example if you're working on a
website and a developer proposes a
change that adds a typo
that's something that can easily be
automatically detected and
if you set up a typogate that says no
change may go in
if it contains a typo that would be an
easy way to make sure that developers
get automatic feedback about their
changes
people say pull requests you know as of
2021
usually they mean git so git is a
technology originally popularized by
linux
and it helps developers make these sets
of changes and share them with each
other
a pull request is usually reviewed by at
least one other programmer and something
called a code review
where the other programmer will tell you
about code style
will tell the proposing programmer
whether there's architectural problems
scaling problems
subjective things that can't easily be
automated but that process of review can
also be
greatly facilitated by a devops
technology stack
and devops automation can help with
things like ephemeral environments and
from
linting and from all of these other
automations that we'll get into
after the code review has been done
usually an engineering manager or
product manager in charge of the
functionality being proposed
will give feedback so if you create a
new button on a website
you'd like the designer that designed
the button and you'd like the product
manager that requested the button be
created
both give feedback because if the button
is phrased poorly if it's placed poorly
if it's not mobile responsive
those are all problems that would
require another merge request so it
would be great if the original merge
request fulfilled all of the
requirements
the first time it was proposed and so
usually non-technical people will give
feedback on pull requests as necessary
so what can be automated for a devops
engineer
you can automate things like automated
test running
per change of femoral environments
automated security scanning
notifications to reviewers getting the
right people to review it at the right
time
and the end goal of all this automation
is that a developer should be able to
propose a change
and get it merged the same day they
propose the change that's a huge
organizational benefit because it means
that
critical bugs can be very quickly fixed
and
merged and deployed without needing a
special process
and it also means that developers aren't
bogged down in bureaucracy
they can propose changes once they get
through all the gates the change will be
deployed
there isn't additional special gates
they need to discover
so for example if the proper gates and
automations have been set up a developer
should be able to change a web page
without having to ask everyone in the
company whether this web page is used in
certain workflows or not
by virtue of passing the tests and
passing the qa review it's assumed that
the new change is good
and if a problem does arise a new gate
can be added to the automation so that
in the future problems don't
occur the second pillar is deployment
automation
in a famous post from 2000 the founder
of stack overflow
places can you make a build in one step
as the second most important question
for a development organization and
things haven't really changed since then
the efficiency of a build process isn't
the only goal
of deployment automation however other
goals include
the deployment strategies i talked about
canary deployments where you want to
show a feature to one user at a time
starting new versions of your
application without causing downtime
if you have to shut off your website
before upgrading it and then turning on
the new version
the visitors that visit the website in
the middle of the upgrade
will notice downtime so there's clever
deployment strategies you can do to
avoid that
and finally rolling back versions in
case something goes wrong
and it's easy to overcomplicate
deployments many companies have complex
internal platforms for building and
distributing releases
broadly success in deployment automation
is finding the appropriate deployment
tools to fulfill business goals and
configuring them
in an ideal world there should be little
to no custom code for deploying
so off-the-shelf solutions like
spinnaker and harness
are wonderful places to start for this
sort of thing
finally application performance
management
even the best code can be hangstrong by
operational errors
there's a famous case where a user put a
bunch of spaces at the end of their post
in stack overflow and they brought down
stack overflow which is a very popular
developer website
because stack overflow hadn't deployed
their code in a way that would deal
well with a bunch of white space so a
bunch of space characters at the end of
a post
even with the best code and even with
the simplest things like just a
messaging board it's easy to have faults
that make it to production and are only
uncovered by users
so application performance management
ensures that metrics like
how long it's taking for requests to be
processed how many servers are being
used
all of those key health metrics are
being processed
and if there's a problem like if all of
the requests to the landing page are
suddenly taking a long time
the appropriate people can be notified
automatically instead of an engineer
discovering on twitter that their
website is down
logging so as a program executes
it will produce logs and the logs
generally have information about the
state of things
it's useful to be able to map backlogs
like you know a user visited the website
with information about that user so what
was their ip address what was their
username
what resource did they access and what
resources were used
for fulfilling that access so if they
had to load something from a database
the database was slow it's useful to be
able to say the user had a slow
experience because
their request was fulfilled slowly but
the request was fulfilled slowly because
it
was fulfilled from the database slowly
so mapping these requests all the way
down to their constituent
components is very useful monitoring so
again i mentioned the metrics and
automatically alerting people but taking
the logs and the metrics how slow are
things
how much memory is left and deciding
what to do so
if there's a bunch of load you might
decide based on the metrics to
automatically scale
the number of servers so add more web
servers as they're being used
based on the logs if there's errors you
might want to automatically file tickets
for engineers to look into them
and if there's a downtime you might want
to call someone
the person on call so that they wake up
and take care of the downtime
they can drop everything they can have a
pager so to speak and that's alerting so
alerting is when
a fault is detected a sum trigger has
occurred based on the metrics
some number of requests are too slow
things are unhealthy you know users are
going to notice degraded performance
someone should be notified or something
should be done some action
a new product shouldn't dive into devops
engineering
all at once so all that i've talked
about are end goals for really large
organizations like netflix and facebook
developers would add automation as the
situation required
so a new startup with no users building
a website pillars two and three are
essentially useless
outages won't be noticed by anyone
something like
a downtime won't be noticed by anyone it
doesn't necessarily matter
you you don't even necessarily need to
run automated tests a useful stack for
someone there would be
something like netlife or cell or our
product where you can get
staging environments to collaborate with
other developers but that's about as far
as you care
for testing-wise you just get an
environment
for every proposed change and you can
play around with it yourself to see
in a manual qa setting whether it's good
or not a team building an app for 10
enterprise users
so enterprise users are much more
sensitive to downtime
so test coverage and business hours
alerting should be priorities
on logging and log aggregation error
collection there's popular tools like
sentry
and code cov for automated test running
there's tools like bitrise and circle ci
bitrise is more known for mobile testing
and for alerting there's a famous tool
called pagerduty that
keeps track of who should be notified if
there's a downtime and so during
business hours you might assign someone
to be the person that
isn't supposed to take any meetings for
the date if there's a downtime they'll
drop everything and solve the problem
and a social media app like reddit might
be using
a large combination of things so sentry
for
catching errors in the website
elasticsearch logsdash cabana is a
popular way of collecting and looking at
logs
a pingdom will check whether certain
pages are taking too long to respond
launch darkly lets you add feature flags
so you can
say whether a feature is enabled for
some group of users or not should the
new landing page be shown to users in
north america or europe
and terraform lets you automate the
deployment process so
given a set of servers and a set of
things that need to run on the servers
terraform will help you automatically
create a plan to
ensure that the right things are running
in the right places
and the conclusion of all of this is
that devops engineering is vital for
developer teams
without being cognizant of its three
pillars customers will have a confusing
and disappointing experience
you know things will go down things
won't scale properly things will be slow
and so it's really important to keep the
three pillars in mind as you're scaling
an engineering organization or if you're
being hired as a devops engineer
new products don't need to automate very
much however
as a product matures and it gets more
users it's more and more important to
automate devops engineering and to
dedicate more resources to it
we go more into code review automation
let's talk about testing
which is going to be really vital
baseline information for when we talk
about continuous integration
and other code review automation topic
so test driven development is a coding
methodology
where tests are written before the code
is written
and you know we're going to explain
tests and test driven development in
terms of coffee makers so enjoy this
picture of a nice coffee maker
as we continue test driven development's
been around for a long
time it was popularized in the early
2000s and the idea is simple
but it requires knowledge of how things
came to be for it to really make sense
so historically common words in software
development like quality assurance qa
and unit tests have roots in factories
building physical products
if you were running a factory building
coffee makers you would test that it
worked at varying levels of completion
so unit tests ensure individual
components work on their own
does the heater work does the tank hold
water
integration tests ensure a few
components work together
does the heater heat the water in the
tank
system end-to-end tests ensure
everything works together
does the coffee maker brew a cup of
coffee
acceptance tests after being launched
sent to customers
are they satisfied with the result are
they confused with the button layout or
breaking
the coffee maker within their warranty
period
all of these tests have software
analogies it's useful to know which
components break
in order to diagnose a problem but it's
also useful to know that the whole
system is working correctly
because even if every individual
component works on its own
if your coffee maker doesn't heat water
with its heater that's going to be a
problem when it comes to making coffee
that's really the idea for testing but
let's get into test driven development
which is the methodology built on top of
testing that's become so popular in the
past
10 or 20 years most developers
that aren't using test driven
developments have a similar workflow
they'll choose something to work on
based on our idea of devops it would be
in the planning phase
the developers would find something to
work on in the planning phase
they'd build it so they'd write code and
they'd make a build from that code
and then they test it so they'd write
small scripts that made sure that their
code was working correctly
if you're making a function that adds
two numbers you might pass it two and
two and expect that the result is four
and that would be a good indication that
your function was working correctly
so steps one and three as it turns out
are very connected
the tests written at the end essentially
codify the specification
what is success for building a coffee
maker it should heat up in 5 seconds
so write a test for that it should brew
coffee of sufficient strength
so write a test for that and so on test
room and development
uses the similarity of steps one and
three to flip this process
so first developers choose something to
work on and then they write the tests
before writing the code so they write
tests that are currently failing
because the specification isn't
satisfied and then they write
code until all of the specifications
they wrote in step two are satisfied
so they might make a testing regimen
that would work if the coffee maker
succeeded
and then build the cheapest coffee maker
which satisfies
that testing regimen and the end result
is the same
so the software is built it's tested and
it matches the specifications
but it's significantly easier in a lot
of cases to write code
if you write the tests first because you
know what you're building and it forces
you to think about
which things are important to work on
and which things can be put into a later
set of changes
so this is a very quick video to discuss
testing
in the next video we'll talk about
continuous integration which is really
the devops continuation of this idea
see you there
[Music]
so we've talked about testing where
developers write scripts that make sure
that their code continues working way
off into the future
years after they've made their code and
that leads us into our discussion of
ci which is really one of the big topics
that people talk about in a devops
context
and ci stands for continuous integration
it refers to developers continuously
pushing small changes to a central
repository
numerous times per day and those changes
are verified by automated computer
software that runs
the tests that the programmers have
defined
so we've gone over what tests are so
let's talk about
why a company would use ci
well ci is really the first step in
automating devops
imagine the very simplest scenario a
single developer is making a program
that will be used by a small group of
users
that developer makes the original
program releases it
and the project slowly builds traction
now imagine that developer has a
critical bug a year later
and they go back to the old code and
they say like gee
this is really bad code i've become a
better programmer since a year ago
i don't really understand what's going
on here but that's really how
development works
programmers get better year after year
and they have to read and understand the
bad code that they wrote just a year ago
and the only way to be confident making
changes to that you know legacy
code that might just be a year old is to
have ci
ci improves developer speed because new
changes can be made confidently without
having to worry about breaking existing
functionality
as long as the tests pass ci also
reduces customer churn
problems in the software are much less
likely to occur if you have
comprehensive tests that run
automatically
as long as you get those check marks you
can be reasonably sure that the core
features of your application will
continue working
so how would you integrate ci into your
development process
first let's talk about the common
branch-based development process that
many
development teams use so first
developers work on a feature branch so
they'll take
the files that are most current the ones
shown to customers at a specific set of
time
they'll branch off of it so they'll make
a new copy of the files
to work on their their feature
independently of all of the other
developers working on things
they'll make changes to the various
components so this feature makes a
change to the mobile app
and to the website and then
on that branch they'll push it back to
the repository which is usually
something like github gitlab or
bitbucket
and then that repository will run ci so
the ci will be configured on the
repository side
it'll run all of the tests that the
programmer has defined
and then the results of those tests will
be attached to the
pull request and the pull request is the
developer asking
to take their code and to merge it into
the central repository that users will
be shown
so you take the feature branch here
and you put it at the end of all of the
other commits that are being shown to
users
and so this commit is now the one that
will be shown to users next
and the next time there's a deployment
the features that the programmer made
will be visible to users
and the best part is it doesn't cost you
anything central gate repositories like
github gitlab and bitbucket
most have generous free tiers even for
organizations minus some security and
access control
you know permissions features that you
might need as you scale up and
ci providers like lci github actions
gitlab pipelines
all have generous free tiers as well
layer ci you know is really made for
people working on
websites that's maybe something to
consider but if you're really early on
in your project's lifecycle it doesn't
really matter which ci provider you use
of course if there's one thing to take
away from the discussion of ci
it's that ci is a vital tool it's really
the first thing that should be automated
in
most pull request automation schemes
because it's so easy
developers should be writing these tests
regardless and so if you don't run the
tests automatically
slowly people will break things without
realizing that they're breaking them
and users will notice those broken
things
and following best practices like
feature branches and ci is a really easy
way to scale a developer team
with just ci a developer team can easily
scale from 1 to 10 developers and at
some point in there you'll have to start
worrying about
other pull request automation topics
like the ones we'll cover in the next
[Applause]
section
[Applause]
[Music]
we've talked a lot about theory but
let's get practical for a little bit
just to round out our understanding of
how these devops concepts work
let's look at what setting up ci looks
like for an actual repository
this is the live chat example it's an
open source version of slack
that's used as a demo repository
throughout layer ci's internal
documentation
let's say for this open source version
of slack we'd like to run tests every
time a developer proposed changes
so that in the pull requests tab we'd be
able to know whether a change was good
in particular let's say a developer was
changing the color of the website in the
main website
after you log in
the top bar and sidebar are purple
perhaps a customer has requested that
the color be blue instead
if we asked a developer and our team to
make this change they would go to the
necessary design file
and edit the color
in this case there are two colors to
change
if the developer opened this pull
request it'd be very difficult for us to
review their change
without a ci system all we can see is
the file change
and the description of the commit so we
can see that they've edited main.css
and that they've changed these color
values but it's very hard to understand
the ramifications of this
and it's especially hard to understand
whether this will have negative side
effects for our existing users
especially for changes that are less
trivial than just changing a color
for this request if i was asked to
review it
i would have to pull these changes onto
my local developer machine
run the script locally and then evaluate
the changes locally
or i could ask the developer to set up a
screen sharing session
and then they could walk me through the
changes both of these add a lot of
friction to the development process
it'd be better if i could evaluate their
changes without needing any involvement
at all entirely through a web interface
that's how continuous integration helps
continuous integration allows developers
to set up comprehensive tests
so that if something doesn't work
anymore after a proposed change
it says right in the pull request
let's close this change for now and look
at the repository
to understand how to set up ci
in this repository one of the services
is called cypress
and it's an end-to-end testing service
it contains several configurations and
these configurations
interact with the page with a fake
browser for example
this test enters a username and password
and then logs in and then
ensures that the user is actually logged
in
this test goes to the message area
enters a random message and ensures that
the message has actually been submitted
that it's viewable in the remaining chat
area
with enough end-to-end tests you can be
reasonably confident that a chat system
like this one
continues working
so we'd like to run these tests every
time a developer proposes a change
to do so we'll have to install a plugin
into github
set up the server to run after every
pull request
and run this test against the new server
to do that let's set up layer cr
for our use cases it's easy to just
install it directly onto our github
account
we can now install it onto our github
repository
and now it's listed here this means that
we've successfully installed layer ci
onto this repository
however nothing will happen yet because
there are no configuration files
we need to set up a configuration file
for this repository that will
start the whole stack and then run the
tests in cyprus as required
let's do that now because our repository
is docker compose based
let's use the docker compose example as
a starting point
here we're going to install docker which
is a containerization technology we'll
talk more about containers versus
virtual machines later on in these sets
of talks
we install docker compose which is again
a way of running multiple containers at
the same time
these these concepts will become clear
later on in this talk
we copy the repository files into the
testrunner we build all of the services
we start all of the services and then we
deploy the pipeline
let's skip deploying for now we'll talk
about that in the deployment section of
this devops course
and after all the services are started
let's run tests
luckily i've already pre-set up a script
for this
so i can copy my configuration
so to recap what this configuration will
do is
install the necessary software in this
case docker and docker compose
copy the repository files build all of
the microservices
start them all locally within the test
runner and then run our tests against
them
so now that we've installed layer ci
onto our repository
all we have to do is add this
configuration and we'll have setup ci
for it
so let's click add file we'll name it
layer file
this is how layer ci's configuration
files are named other ci providers will
have different file names of course
we'll copy our configuration
and we'll commit the file
so now that we've set up ci we can see
that
there's a dot next to the commit name
and that dot turns into a check mark
when the tests have passed
this means that every time a developer
pushes new code in our source code
management tool
they'll get a success metric namely
whether the tests have passed or not
automatically
they won't have to run the test
themselves and the reviewer won't have
to trust that the
original developer has actually tested
that
the change works so let's go back to our
original proposed change of changing the
colors
in production from blue to purple
here we're going to make our change and
reopen the pull request
but because we've configured a ci
provider for it
we'll be able to see that the tests are
running automatically directly in the
pull request view itself
now when our developer asks us for a
review it'll be much easier for us to be
able to tell whether the change has
negatively
affected our customers workflows in
particular because we've configured
cypress
and layer ci to check that logging in
and posting messages still work
we'll know that for this change even
though
many files might have been changed the
core workflows still work which gives us
a degree of confidence that
nothing terribly bad has happened with
the code
so we can look at the file change for
our first idea of what the developer has
done
and then we can view what the ci is
doing so if we open the relevant
pipeline
we'll see that the tests are in progress
of running the new version of the
application has been built
and started within the ci runner and the
tests are
running one by one here it's tested that
you can post chat messages within our
alternative slacks chat page
the landing page loads and logging in
works correctly
so now within our pull request view
we'll be able to see
a big check mark here which shows that
all of the relevant ci checks have
passed
and then you can even automate within
github or other source code management
platforms
that certain checks must pass entirely
so you can automate that
all ci checks must pass before a change
could be merged
let's make sure that developers are
never reviewing code that's so obviously
broken that it's breaking your tests
and you don't only have to run
end-to-end tests here you can also run
linters unit tests and other versions of
tests which we talk about throughout
this
series of talks and now that i'm happy
with the change
i've reviewed the files and i see that
the ci has passed
i can merge it with a great deal more
confidence than if i didn't have this
automation in place
that's it for setting up ci in an
applied setting let's get back to theory
for a little bit
[Music]
continuing on the topic of testing and
continuous integration
let's talk about code coverage so code
coverage quantitatively measures
how comprehensive the tests for a
codebase are you might think that
you have enough tests to find all of the
common bugs and to really
check all of the functionality of your
app but it's hard to put a number on it
unless you're measuring code coverage
this is what a code coverage graph looks
like from a popular tool
each of these squares represents a file
and the color represents how many tests
are covering that file so bright green
means 100
of the file is tested and bright red
means none of the file is tested so that
would be a priority of a file that
should either be tested or excluded from
the measurement
so let's say you're taking over an
existing code base it's relatively large
at 100 000 lines of code over the years
it's been adopted by a couple hundred
users
and you're expected to maintain it and
add features without harming those users
so the first place you look at is the
unit tests which we discussed earlier
but they weren't really prioritized by
the previous maintainers so there's a
mismatch of libraries and naming
conventions and it's kind of hard to
tell
which tests are testing which files and
which files need to be tested
and before you write any new features
you'd like an objective way to measure
how sensitive certain parts of the
codebase are to being changed
if something has very comprehensive
tests you'll be much
less scared to make changes and add
features that touch that part of the
code
than if there's a part of the code that
doesn't have tests
so this is where code coverage really
shines you've got a complicated code
base that has
existing users and you'd like to enforce
that tests are written
so that things aren't broken in an
objective way
so getting into the first code of this
whole series
let's look at this javascript function
which i will make bigger
so this is a very simple function if not
a bit contrived
it takes a number and it defines
a few variables it loops up to that
number
pushing strings into a results
list and then every 50 elements it
pushes a special string into the results
list
so this whole function is 10 lines of
code
but not all 10 lines are equal so
really there's three kinds of lines in a
program like this
there's the syntax lines like these
closing ones that don't actually have
any code in them they're simply
syntactic
constructs for the programmer's benefit
they don't you know it doesn't even make
sense to test these because how would
you test that a
semicolon existed or not
there's logic lines like this one which
actually have side effects
and by side effects i mean that these
lines if you remove them
would change the behavior of the program
and there's branch lines like this one
which change the flow of the program
so for loops and if statements in
programming
are used as constructs that change the
order of the
commands that run so this if statement
if it evaluates to true
would run this line and if it didn't
evaluate to true it wouldn't run this
line
so to reiterate the three kinds of lines
are
syntactical ones that don't do anything
the
actual logic ones that have
effects and the branch ones that
change which lines of code execute
and code coverage is usually defined as
line coverage so it's the ratio
of the non-syntax lines
which are executed by tests over the
total number of non-syntax lines
so again consider this test
if you expect the function should work
with the input 2
and you manually calculate what the
function should return for the input 2
this would be a unit test for your
function
but since you're only executing it on
the input 2 this if statement which
requires an input of at least 50 to
execute
i wouldn't run so you'd be testing this
line
it would execute this line it would
execute
and this line which would also execute
so you'd be executing
five out of six lines
and indeed that would be 83 test
coverage
though just the single test gets us most
of the way to understanding
our function and understanding its
problems
a related concept is called branch
coverage so
instead of measuring how many lines of
code it measures groups of lines
in our example above there's only two
branches there is
the main branch there's the body
of the for loop and there's actually
a third branch called the if statement
body
so here this line will always execute
the body of the for loop will only
execute if
i is less than n so here you need
n to be greater than or equal to 1 for
these lines to execute and this line
will only execute if i
greater than or equal to 49. and so
branch coverage would be how many
individual branches
out of these three are evaluated to true
by a test so you'd like to know how many
of all of the branches
are tested and this is useful because if
this line of code executes
then this line of code will always
execute so treating them
both as individual things that need to
be tested doesn't really mean as much as
taking the bodies of these statements as
things that need to be tested
and if you measured the test with branch
coverage you'd see that two of the three
branches are
evaluated during the test so when should
you care about this
line coverage in branch coverage we've
already discussed one scenario
where you've inherited an existing code
base however it's important in many
different
situations in general you should measure
and optimize for code coverage if any of
the following are true
so your product has users and those
users might leave if they're affected by
bugs
in which case it's important to measure
code coverage because it lets you
work with your team to improve the code
coverage and reduce the number of bugs
you're working with developers that
aren't immediately trustworthy like
contractors or interns that you're you
know bringing them into your code base
they need to make changes in some fixed
time scale like a format internship
so they can't immediately become experts
in the entire code base
and you'd like them to be able to make
changes without worrying too much about
things breaking
or if you're working in a very large
code base with many individually
testable components
here code coverage analysis can
complement test driven development which
we talked about in the previous talk
to make sure that everyone on the team
is generally working on important things
and that the things they make won't
break in the future
so it's a common mistake in code review
automation to make things too rigid
before the product has enough users
if you force developers to get 100
branch coverage
so to write two to five unit tests for
every function it's going to make them
much slower
at developing features that users will
actually notice
remember that tests are never viewed by
users
so the only thing that users care about
is the stability of the system
so if you have an mvp or if you have a
product that doesn't have very many
active users yet
it might not be worth it to measure or
optimize for branch coverage
until those users care a lot about
stability
and by writing unit tests and other
types of tests
an important thing to keep in mind is
that developers are solidifying the
implementations of features that they
might have to throw out
if you build a feature and it ends up
not being something that your users
actually want
it's always a better idea to throw out
that feature than
build it long term so if a developer
builds a feature and writes many tests
for it to improve the code coverage of
that feature
they'll be much more likely not to throw
it out because they'll feel a sense of
ownership and they'll feel a sense of
sunk cost
in having built this feature and made it
good so to speak
so it's important not to over optimize
for these things before they're
important
and it's a subjective idea but really
you'll notice
when your users start complaining about
stability
so organizationally there are some
common policies related to code coverage
the first one is useful when you inherit
a code base and the policy is that code
coverage must not decrease
this one is one of the easiest ones to
automate it's especially useful if
you're taking over an existing code base
as i mentioned
and the idea is that code coverage ratio
should never decrease
if the current code has 75 of its lines
tested
and your new change introduces 40 lines
of code
at least 30 of those lines will need to
be tested
otherwise your changes code coverage
would be less than 75
30 out of 40 and you'd be decreasing the
average code coverage
as with most code coverage policies this
will increase stability so there'll be
less bugs because things will be better
tested
at the expense of developer speed so
developers will have to make some
complicated tests and they might spend a
lot of time making testing
infrastructure
so features will be shipped less quickly
if you make this sort of
policy and if you enforce it with a
code review automation
unfortunate side effect of this policy
is that changes that would be harder to
test
such as integrations will be less likely
to be worked on by developers
so developers are incentivized by their
paycheck and by their manager to
ship features quickly to make many
features per scrum cycle
and so if certain features are harder to
test because they require internet
connectivity or
connect to third-party apis those
features will be harder to make and
harder to test
and so developers will be less likely to
make them regardless of whether they're
important to the users or not
so it might be useful to have an
exemptions policy in place for things
like third-party integrations
if your organization decides to go for
this code coverage must not decrease
policy
another useful policy is code owners for
test files
if you've used code coverage automation
to keep code while tested
it's often beneficial to define code
owners for the tests themselves
this means that developers can change
implementation details without formal
reviewers
but logic changes so the tests define
what success means for
a function or for an algorithm then
changing the tests for a new
implementation would need to be approved
by a senior developer or manager
in github with an engineering manager a
github code owner's file might contain
this which means dotspec.js
is a common javascript testing
naming convention and at engineering
manager username means if
if there's a file called code owners
which contains this
then the engineering manager will need
to approve any change which changes a
test
which is probably a good policy
so if you're working in a large code
base with test driven development
especially
or if you're hiring interns or
contractors or if your users are
especially sensitive to bugs
and you're afraid that they'll have a
bad experience if the even small bugs
make it to them
it might be in your team's best interest
to install a code coverage measurement
tool
and at the time of writing these are the
three most common ones in
the open source world a code cov
coveralls
and code climate
so we've talked about testing and we've
talked about continuous integration
and those are really like the initial
things that are set up in a devops coder
view automation pipeline
but the problem is that it requires the
developers to be on board
and of course developers are probably
busy building features and might not
necessarily want to
make tests or improve test coverage so
let's talk about linting
which is something that approximates
testing but doesn't need the developers
to spend any time
linters are programs that look at a
program's source code
and find problems automatically they're
a common feature of pull request
automation
because they ensure that obvious bugs do
not make it to production
obvious here in quotes so an example of
linting
let's again look at a javascript program
a very simple one
you should understand even if you don't
know javascript
it defines a variable var x equals five
it defines a function but continues
after the open bracket which is you know
generally considered by practice
it uses let for the second variable and
defines it with the same name as the
first one so this is just confusing and
you know it wouldn't be called good code
a code reviewer would mention this in a
code review
and then it says while x is less than
100 console log
x and then it closes the while loop on
this line and it messes up the indent
these three lines should be indented for
consistency
and then it closes the function finally
you should realize that this while loop
goes forever x isn't incremented in the
body of the while loop so just by
looking at the code statically
without running any environment or
looking at the code
with a browser even you can tell that
this loop will run forever and that's
probably something that programmer
didn't intend
so much of this feedback
could be automated a set of rules like
don't shadow variables never name a
variable in an inner scope that has the
same name as a variable in an outer
scope
could be applied to each proposed change
so that human reviewers would not have
to waste effort
leaving code style comments tools that
maintain
and run such lists are called linters
relevantly another class of code review
feedback has to do with code style
it's easy for coder viewers to waste
time pointing out stylistic choices like
tabs versus bases or
camelcase versus pothole case these
discussions bring no value to end users
you know your customers don't care
what case your code is written in and
ultimately they just
serve to cause resentment and miss
deadlines within engineering teams
if a review takes an extra couple hours
because of comments like this
that's a couple hours that the
programmer could have been focusing
their attention on another feature
so engineering organizations should
eventually
adopt to maintain a global style guide
but in most cases just starting with
something like the google style guide
which is open source and available
at this link is a great starting point
these guides often come with linter
configurations which help everything
stay stylistically similar and some
programming languages like python and go
come with their own style guides and
automation like pep 8 in the case of
python that will
make it easy for developers using those
programming languages to stay in a
unified style
an organizational thing you can do for
code style is
to knit or which stands for nitpicking
instead of blocking at the code review
stage if there's review
feedback that uh you know code style
review feedback
it might be better for coder viewers to
leave small review comments called mitts
so they'd say knit full colon shouldn't
be styled this way
this is great because it allows the
reviewers to
merge something with a few pieces of
feedback so that hours don't have to be
spent on
a small piece of refactoring that could
be done at a later stage at a later
point in time
once the style guide is adopted it's
possible to configure tools to
automatically format code to follow the
style guide
such tools are called autoformatters in
the programming language go
which we use at layer ci a command such
as the following
would use the standard formatter the one
that comes with go to clean up all of
the source files in the repository
so we'd use the gnu find command
find the files that have a go extension
and we'd exec go format on them
and this will take all of the source
files and then format them with our
style guide so that they all pass the
style guide
and of course if your ci system is
running tests automatically every time
your code is pushed the code could be
automatically linted as well
programmers shouldn't have to wait for a
human reviewer to tell them whether the
code is linted and styled appropriately
in most cases it's cheap and convenient
to run linting and formatting
automatically with an sci system
so an easy solution is you get another
check mark
to get something set up quickly it's a
good start to make lint act the same as
running a unit test in ci
so add an x if the code isn't linted
properly
and then the developer can very quickly
get stylistic feedback without needing
to talk to another human or wasting
their reviewers time for getting this
sort of feedback and a ci configuration
that might look like this
so copy the project files run the
lending script
and then if the linking script fails the
whole pipeline would fail
this approach stops reviewers from the
picking style it passed the linter is a
perfectly reasonable response to an
overly zealous code reviewer
so even simple automation like this can
improve the development speed
of entire development teams it also
stops reviewers from having to give
style feedback at
all if all of the checks for coder view
pass
like it passes all of the linters then
the commit is stylistically okay
the reviewer might still leave some
feedback for future reference but they
shouldn't be a blocking commits getting
to production because of
small stylistic choices that aren't even
in the lyncher
a better long-term solution is to set up
a commit back bot
which is a common idea that happens all
over the place
in code review automation but in this
specific example it might look like this
so you'd say if the code is not linted
run eslint with the dash fix flag
which again goes through all of the
source files eslint is the linter for
javascript
so this would go through all of the
source files for each of them
it would apply the linting
rules and it would fix any stylistic
errors
and then it would create a commit
and an additional you know set of file
changes on top of what the developer is
proposing
and it would create a new branch with
the suffix linted
and it would push to that branch
so that a developer pushes unlimited
code
the bot would automatically create a
commit which linted everything and it
would create a new branch
so that if the developer's code was
known to be good
the reviewer could simply merge the
linted branch instead of the developer's
original one
and then we failed the pipeline with the
lint failed this means that the
unlimited version can't be merged
but the linted one assuming all the
feedback that isn't linted related
could be merged so we'd have two
branches the
one the developer's proposing and the
limited one the coder viewer would look
at the one that wasn't linted
they'd say whether it was good or not
like the logic of the commit was good
and if it was good then the reviewer in
github
could merge this branch instead of the
one they
were asked to review this branch would
be the same as the original one with an
additional commit on top of it
so some examples of linters for many
programming languages
javascript the standard as of 2021 is
eslint
typescript also now uses eslint
python uses pylint and flake8
c plus is much more subjective but a
common choice is google cpplint
from the google style guide mentioned
above
go comes with a formatter called go
format which acts somewhat like a linter
although there's additional libraries
available for
rules beyond that java has check style
and find bugs
maybe older options but there's a lot of
choices for languages like java
and ruby has rubocop and pronto we've
seen
users commonly use and java
javascript c-sharp and many other
languages can be linted with sonar cube
which is a popular
static analysis framework that is
commonly used at
larger enterprises but it has an open
source version it is a good place to
start for
10 developer teams that would like to
set up static analysis
and finally there's a startup called
deep source that we've talked to
startup to startup and they're doing all
sorts of interesting stuff with static
analysis as well
static analysis is just the practice of
looking at source code without running
it
and finding bugs so i'd encourage you to
look at deep source as well
so in comparison to most other code
automation tools linters are
exceptionally easy to set up
any team with more than one developer
should almost immediately set up a
linter
to catch obvious bugs like infinite
loops just by looking at the code the
linter would be able to tell you
whether there was a common programmatic
error like an infinite loop
automatic linting comes standard with
many code editors so it would be wise to
teach developers
how to configure their code editors to
use the existing
linting rules that your team has set up
in the ci automation
so that the developers don't have to
wait to push their code to get this
feedback they can get the yellow
squigglies directly in their editor
and in teams working on earlier products
linters can help avoid writing unit
tests at all
instead of relying on a test suite you
can rely often on
a static analysis to find common bugs
like the code not compiling at all
or infinite loops or stylistic problems
this helps small teams before their
product as many users get feedback
without needing to lock things
in with tests all right so that's it for
linting and code style we'll see in the
next video
let's finish up our discussion of code
review automation by talking about
ephemeral environments
which are really the latest and greatest
when it comes to doing code reviews and
helping developers get their changes
merged
ephemeral environments are temporary
environments that contain a
self-contained version
of the entire application generally for
every feature branch
they're often spun up by a slack bot or
automatically on every commit using
devops platforms like layer ci itself or
heroku
temporary environments are overtaking
traditional ci platforms
as the most valuable devops coder view
experience
because these environments are made on
every change all of the stakeholders
not just developers but the product
people and the designers
can review a change without needing to
set up a developer environment or asking
to screen share with the developer that
proposed it
so for a more concrete example let's say
a developer is
changing something on a website so
they're changing
you know the front end or the back end
or you know
some component of the website and they'd
like to get feedback on their proposed
change
so a coder viewer would look at the code
and they might not understand what the
visual ramifications of that change are
but within ephemeral environment within
the code review view itself
the reviewer would just have to click
that button there
i'll zoom in so within github this is
what the
reviewer would see they'd see the
description the code change
but also a button to view the ephemeral
environment and when they click that
button
it wakes up a version of the website
specifically with this proposed change
in it
so that the reviewer can actually take a
look at things and
see whether the changes visually
and workflow wise working well
in general ephemeral environments lie
halfway between development environments
and staging environments
at the extreme staging is entirely
replaced by thermal environments
and something called continuous staging
benefits of ephemeral environments well
the most common reason to adopt an
ephemeral environment workflow is that
it
is that it accelerates the software
development life cycle
developers can review the results of
changes visually instead of needing to
exclusively give feedback on the code
change itself
additionally developers can share their
work with non-technical collaborators
such as designers
as easily as sharing a link to the
proposed version
so you could post a slack message like
this
saying could you go to this link and
give me feedback instead of needing to
set up a zoom call to share your screen
to get the other person to look at your
proposed changes
the hardest part of setting up ephemeral
environments are dealing with state
so dealing with things like databases
and microservices
by their nature you know ephemeral
environments are temporary
they're isolated from production
environments and really only last as
long as a pull request does
a reviewer should be able to delete a
resource in a review
so they should be able to see if you
know deleting a user still works
without fear of that affecting the
production environment
so in the early implementation of
ephemeral environments
it might make sense to connect to api
servers with read-only permissions to a
staging
database so if you're using aws you
might have an iam role that has
read-only access to the database
but in that case you wouldn't be able to
sign up to the service for example
because that would require a database
right
the end goal should be to have a fresh
copy of the database for every commit
so every time a developer proposes a
change they get
a new database specifically for their
environment that they can do whatever
they want
and an ideal ephemeral database has
three attributes
it's pre-populated so it contains
representative anonymized data
the past security audits all pii
personally identifiable information must
be scrubbed from databases used in
ephemeral environments
it should be undoable so if in the
course of a review
data is deleted it should be easy to
reset the database to its original state
this is also crucial for running
destructive end-to-end tests
which we'll get into later and it should
be migrated
the database should use the schema
currently used in production it's not
very useful to know if something's
working with an old version of the
schema
one of the most common classes of
problems uncovered by female
environments are broken
or non-performant database migrations
another hard problem to solve with
ephemeral environments is the life cycle
so when would you create them and when
you destroy them
a classic approach is to title life
cycle of a pull request
to the life cycle of an ephemeral
environment so if the developer opens a
pull request
create an environment for them keep it
running 24 7 until
the developer deletes the environment
the biggest factor i consider there is
cost if each ephemeral environment costs
10 percent of production so it's 10
cheaper and you have 30 open pull
requests you'd be quadrupling your
monthly costs
so you know that's a an expensive
developer tool
another approach is to create a chat op
spot that allows creating new
environments for a specific branch
with a specific timeout so for example
the user type slash
prbot create in the github
issue description that could create an
environment or in slack the user could
do the same thing
this requires the environment to be
provisioned at the time that it's
required which can be slow
and uh it's again hard to tell when to
delete these
the best approach is to create an
ephemeral environment for every change
so similar to the pr workflow but
hibernate them as they're provisioned um
there's only a few providers that do
this
so one is heroku which will with heroku
review app can turn on and off
environments
and the other one is layer ci uh
shameless plug i suppose
so as users use the environments in
layer ci they'll be hibernated and on
and off
you can automate this yourself with
memory snapshotting but it's somewhat
involved so
this might be something that's better
left to using a third party for
and back to that idea of continuous
staging
the idea is to merge staging ephemeral
environments in a ci pipeline
altogether so this is kind of what layer
ci itself
primarily sells to our users as your
ephemeral environments become more
powerful and easier
to create they approach and overtake
many
aspects of traditional continuous
integration pipelines
so if you can set up the website and the
backend and the database
then it's relatively easy to run tests
because tests are usually much
easier to run than the entire back end
at its logical conclusion
this concept becomes continuous staging
where ci cd
and ephemeral environments form a single
ci cd flow where
a single base sets up all of the
requirements for everything
and then that forks off into the unit
tests but also the server but also
the review environment but also the
linter which everything comes from that
common base
um if you're going to make them yourself
you should probably budget
about a month per month of time it took
to set up your environment
so if your production environment has
many different microservices and has
many different databases
it'll be relatively difficult to set up
an environmental environment flow
large companies like facebook have set
this up for their internal pull requests
but they have entire developer teams
infrastructure software engineers
that do this so if you're a smaller
company you might want to stick to a
hosted service again like layer ci
instead of making it yourself up to
maybe when you have about 20 developers
and to avoid having to micromanage
starting and stopping environments
it's easiest to use the hosted provider
if you're doing just front-end
development
some popular choices are versal and
netlify
but if you're doing full stack
deployment really the only choices
available right now are layer ci itself
and heroku review apps there are some
options available in many source code
platforms like
git lab has a environments feature
but it's not really truly an ephemeral
environments feature so you should
explore all of those options to make an
informed decision
so that was thermal environments and
that concludes our discussion of
code review automation
[Music]
because pull request automation is such
a core part of devops engineering
let's do another applied tutorial here
in this example we'll be setting up
ephemeral environments
the same way we talked about before
using a hosted platform
for the sake of simplicity so
because we've already set up ci for this
repository we already have our layer
file
which is our ci configuration however
many ci providers
including layer ci heroku and others
can set up ephemeral environments which
are small production deployments you can
use
to evaluate the changes live as a
reviewer
again let's say we're changing the color
this time back from blue to purple
and we'd like someone to be able to
efficiently review our change
not just by looking at the test results
but also by looking at the
femoral environment to run manual qa you
might see
in this case it's actually very easy to
set up
let's go to our web microservice
let's create a new file
here we'll make another layer file so
that they run in parallel
we'll say from our base layer file
we'll say expose website
and we'll expose the website running
inside the runner itself
layer ci has this exposed website
directive but many other providers
have similar functionality that you can
set up
and let's jump right to creating a pull
request for it
so here our coder viewer would not only
see the test results
as you can see those are here the
initial
layer file let's look at the actual
graph to understand better what's going
on here we have our tests running in the
main layer file
the main layer file has again built all
of the services
started all of the services and now it's
running our cypress tests
the same way it did in the ci chapter
but after those cypress tests run we'll
have a second environment which is
inheriting from the first and that
second environment will have a clickable
link
that can be used for manual qa
so let's see that here the snapshot is
done being taken
of the tests which means that the
ephemeral environment can start being
built
and now you can see that it's built a
staging server button
and you can connect to it here so in our
actual pull request
now that all of the tests and ci
services have passed
we can click the ephemeral environment
button
as soon as it appears
we could click the main layer file
details
we can click the services web ephemeral
environment
and we can click view website and what
this does is it wakes up the
pipeline which we initially set up to
run our tests
but it forwards the internet visible
link
to the web server inside so here we've
created a fresh environment
specifically for this test and we can
see that the test has run and sent a
message
and we can evaluate this change so we
can test that creating channels the
works for example
and that in the test channel it's still
possible to set messages
this means that you don't need 100 test
coverage to be able to understand
the nuance of a change for every pull
request you'll be able to spin up
a new environment automatically and then
wake up that environment when a review
needs to be completed
and now that we're satisfied that the
environment works correctly we can merge
the pull request
and from now on all changes which edit
the website
can be manually queued so the reviewer
can check
that things work but also a qa team or a
designer or a product
manager might be able to check that the
change actually changes what it's
supposed to
that's it for our thermal environments
let's get back to theory
[Music]
welcome to devops academy deployment in
this one we'll be talking about
foundational concepts
and primarily when you talk about
deploying you're talking about vms
and you're talking about containers uh
and containers are often also known as
docker
so let's talk about the difference
between those two before we talk about
deploying anything
people talk about devops deployments
they're usually talking about deploying
to linux
a large portion of all deployments are
the linux servers
and containers are really only defined
in terms of linux
in production as of right now
so with all that in mind let's talk
about linux in the abstract
so what linux really helps you do
is take care of four things when you're
writing programs
it takes care of memory so programs need
memory to do things
memory is also known as ram and since
you only have a finite amount of it
uh linux itself needs to figure out
which programs will get which
sections of memory so which ram sticks
will have which programs running on them
linux also takes care of processors so
if you're running two things in parallel
linux will make sure that the right
amount of processors are dedicated to
both
if you're if you've ever run very
computationally intensive tasks on a
laptop
you might notice that your browser gets
laggy that's because it's not getting
enough processor time
so if you're running production
workloads linux needs to make sure that
every program is getting its fair share
of processor time to run
the actual program there's disk
so linux takes the files if all programs
and allocate space on the disk for them
you might have multiple disks and you
might have both spinning disks and solid
state drives
you might even have discs shared across
networks so linux takes care of all of
that and make sure that
the right files are on the right disks
and that programs have access to those
files
and finally there's devices so even
beyond disk
memory and cpu there's things like gpu
so
for machine learning you see gpu often
and things like network cards which you
use for connecting to the internet
linux needs to take these individual
resources and allocate them to processes
so if you have five processes trying to
connect to the internet at the same time
but only one network card
linux needs to make sure that the right
messages are sent to the right websites
upstream and the responses are sent to
the right programs downstream
so in a diagram this is what that would
look like
so here we have three programs chrome
notepad and spotify
and they're all running in linux so this
is assuming you have a linux
a server running these three programs
and here you have the four shared
resources
so chrome asks for cpu and linux will
allocate
some of the cpu time to chrome and it'll
also allocate some to notepad and some
to spotify
and similarly for all the other shared
resources
so this is great but there's too much
sharing going on and what i mean by that
is that
programs know about each other so
if you had a program that expected a
file at
home calling file.text then it could
create that file
but another program could delete or read
that file so
files could be read across programs and
that means those programs can
communicate between each other
which isn't always what you want so
for example programmers often use
different versions of python python is a
popular programming language and there's
two popular versions used
one is python 2 and one is python 3 but
they're both called python
so if the file at user bin python
is a python 2 executable and you try to
run a python 3 program with it
then that program would error because
you'd be using the wrong version of
python to run it
however some of your programs might need
python 2 and some of them might be
python 3.
so here there's crosstalk between
programs in that they're both reading
user bin python
but they expect there to be different
files there so that's what i mean by
programs over share sometimes
they need different versions of files at
the same place
and so you can't really run both
programs at the same time
similarly two web servers might listen
to port 80
that's how websites allow you to connect
to them so if you're running
two web servers that both expect port 80
to be open the first one will start
correctly and the second one will crash
saying that port 80 is already used
these sorts of problems of sharing
resources
is really where virtual machines and
containers shine
they allow you to separate resources
like files and ports between programs
so that programs can't step on each
other's feet
so here if you were running your three
programs in a container
it would look remarkably similar so
chrome
would be running but it would be running
within a container
and that container would be talking to
linux which would then allocate the
container resources
and similarly for the other programs
now this might not make sense yet but
let's talk about
what actually happens when you put
something in a container like this so
what happens when there's a container
between a program and linux
the big change is that each program will
get its own
version of shared resources like files
and network ports
the container running chrome might
create a file at
uh tilde slash chrome cache
while the container running notepad
could read that file and see that it
didn't exist
they'd get different copies of all of
the system's files so that they couldn't
talk amongst each other
or have conflicting python versions
similarly if you had two web servers
running that both expected to be able to
open port 80
one would be able to open port 80 in
their container and the other would be
able to open port 80 in their container
so you could have two programs both
thinking that they were the only program
listening on port 80
but really they'd be isolated within
their own containers
so in linux containers work by creating
namespaces which are a linux feature
that group shared resources together
if you had five processes running
together within a docker container
they'd still be running within linux
itself but they would not see the other
processes
the ones on the main linux machine
itself
so within the container if you ran ps
aux and you counted how many lines of
output there were
yes aux is how you see the running
commands in a linux machine
you might see 10 and that means that
there's 10 processes
visible to you within the container but
within linux
so within the container up here if you
said how many processes were running
it would say there's 10 processes but
within linux itself you'd see hundreds
of processes running
including the 10 from this container so
the containers are kind of sandboxed or
namespaced
into a single group of processes where
the processes can't see
the files outside of the container or
the processes or the
network ports outside of the container
they only see the
ports within this container so
essentially what's happening
is the programs are asking what are the
contents of userlib python
in our example before and instead of
answering truthfully
linux is answering with the contents of
another file so the container says what
is user lit python
and then docker if you were using docker
for your containers
would respond with the contents of this
file var lib
docker overlay fs1 user libpython which
is a totally separate file in the global
system
so each container would have its own
view of the files
this little deception allows programs to
run in parallel because linux would be
would respond with different files for
each container one container could have
python pointing out a python 2
executable
and one container can have python
pointing out a python 3 executable
so if that's how containers work then
how do vms work and how are they
different
well vms are very similar to emulators
if you've ever seen someone
running an older video game on a modern
computer they're using a vm
so the idea for containers was to
provide fake
linux within the container they don't
really know they're running with it
within a container they see files but
the files are simply pointing at a
different place
within the real linux installation the
idea for vms is to produce fake versions
one level below that
so p produce fake versions of the cpu
ram
disk and devices the vm equivalent of
docker is called a hypervisor
it's the program which is in charge of
creating the vms so when a vm is running
something it corresponds to an instance
of the hypervisor
within linux the hypervisor might lie to
the vm and say there's one ssd attached
so there's one drive attached and it has
50 gigabytes of capacity
but then when the vm writes to that
drive
it would instead go to a file it
wouldn't go to a real drive
and then on the host it might be this
file
so when the vm itself is writing to the
file it's actually going to this file
which is very similar to the deception
of matching files directly
that the container had but there's some
practical differences
the first is that vms are very powerful
you could use them to run other
operating systems such as mac os or
windows
and different hardware configurations
you can emulate a gamecube or an apple
ii
within a linux hypervisor
in containers it's the processes that
are being lied to
they must still have been the sort of
thing that would run within linux itself
but in vms there's a nested operating
system that generally doesn't know it's
not talking to the real hardware
when the os writes things to its drive
for example
those rights are sent to a file in linux
instead of a physical drive
so when the process
writes to the operating system
within the vm that operating system
sends the right to a drive
or what it thinks is a drive but that
drive goes through linux
and linux actually maps it to a file
various benchmarks show that cpus and
vms
are about 10 to 20 percent slower than
containers
vms also usually use 50 to 100 more
storage
because they need all of the things that
an operating system would need
duplicate containers don't need all of
the files they only need the application
files
and finally vms use about 200 megabytes
more memory for the operating system
itself
again containers don't need all of the
operating system because it's the
processes that are being lied to
so vms use more memory they're slower
and they need more storage
so given these performance benefits it
looks like containers are almost always
a better choice
and in most cases they are however
there's a few cases where vms are a
better choice again vms mean virtual
machines
if you're running untrusted so
user-supplied code
it's difficult to be confident that they
can't escape a container
this has gotten better in recent years
but it's long been a contentious point
virtual machines are much older and much
more mature so if you're running
untrusted code
usually it's a good idea to put that
within a container
if you're running a windows or mac os
script
so you're running a script that only
runs in another operating system
you'd need to use a vm for similar
reasons or if you're running an old
video game that doesn't run in linux and
you'd like to run it on a linux computer
you need a vm and vice versa if you're
using vms and other operating systems
if you'd like to run a linux program in
windows you'd usually have to use a vm
to run it
and finally you can emulate hardware
devices like graphics cards with a vm
so if you're testing that your graphics
card works correctly you could
emulate the response that it would give
and then test that the operating system
is working as expected so that's the big
difference between vms and containers
and these are really the two things that
you often deploy
so let's go on to actual deployment
strategies in the next talk
i'll see you there
[Music]
let's keep talking about deployments so
rolling deployments are one of the most
popular
deployment strategies and we'll talk
about the pros and cons of different
deployment strategies throughout this
section
only deployments themselves work by
starting a new version of the
application
sending traffic to the new version to
make sure everything's okay and then
shutting off the old version and
repeating that until
all versions of the old version are
versions of the new version
i realize i've said version many times
so let's look at pictures which will
help illustrate the point
this is the mirn app mirn stands for
mongodb
nodejs react and express.js
here the user's web browser connects to
both a front end and a back end where
front end is the stuff that the user
sees and back end is the services that
provide connections to the database so
if you log in you're connecting to the
back end
if you're just viewing the landing page
you're connecting to the front end
let's say your app has enough traffic
that users will notice if it goes down
for a little while
how would you push a new version of the
application without causing downtime
this is where rolling deployments come
in the high-level algorithm for a
rolling deployment
looks like this so you create an
instance of the new version
of the back end say you wait until it's
up
so you keep trying to connect to it
until you get a response that's
satisfactory
and then you delete an old version and
route the traffic to the new version
if any instances of the old version
still exist uh go back to step one and
repeat
in our myrn example we'd initially see
three instances of the initial version
and one instance of the new version
and we'd repeat the process until we had
three instances of the new version in
one instance of the initial version
so here all of the
versions are the back end and then we
add a new version of the new back end
and we turn off a version
of the old back end and we keep
repeating that so as time goes on
the red ones replace the pink ones and
then
after a few loops of this the only ones
remaining are red ones we've added a red
one removed the pink one added a red one
removed a pink one and where red is the
newest version of the application
so what are the benefits of rolling
deployments over other ways of deploying
things
well they're well supported rolling
deployments are relatively
straightforward to implement in most
cases
they're natively supported and several
orchestrators if you've heard of
kubernetes for example
kubernetes helps you with this aws
amazon elastic beanstalk
also supports rolling deployments
they don't have huge bursts so in
another deployment strategy which we'll
talk about
if you had three versions of the back
end you'd need to start
six in total to deploy the new version
and then you turn off
the old three so it doubles for the
duration of the deployments the amount
of things running
which might be difficult if you have a
finite number of servers for example
it's also not uncommon for services like
databases
to limit the amount of connections so if
you had
six versions of the back end connecting
to the database now that might be too
much load on the database so that could
cause problems
and rolling deployments are easily
reverted if
in the course of an upgrade you notice
problems it's usually easy to reverse
the rolling deployment by just going in
the opposite direction removing a red
adding a pink
you can go in the opposite direction as
well to roll back which is an important
characteristic of deploying because
things always go wrong
the downsides of rolling deployments are
they can be slow to run
so if you have 100 replicas and you're
replacing one at a time
and it takes 20 seconds it would take 2
000 seconds
to replace all of the versions which is
quite a long time for a deployment
this can be mitigated by increasing the
number of services being turned on and
showed off at a time
which is sometimes called a burst limit
or a rolling deployment size
the other problem is api compatibility
which is the biggest problem of rolling
deployments
so if you add a new version of an api
endpoint to your back end
and consume it in your front end then
since you're not switching them both
at the same time you might have version
one of your back end
serving a request for version two of
your front end
and then that api wouldn't exist so
there'd be errors visible to the user
for the duration of the deployment
this can be medicated with complicated
routing techniques but it's generally
better to make apis backwards compatible
so make version 2 of the front end be
compatible with version 1 of the back
end
so rolling deployments are relatively
simple to understand and generally well
supported
if your user's mind when there's
downtime it's an excellent first step
to deploy using a rolling deployment
strategy the key programming
consideration is to ensure that services
can consume both the old version and the
new version
of services apis if this contract is
violated
users might see errors for the duration
of the deployment let's talk more about
deployment strategies
and we'll go into blue-green deployments
[Music]
next
another deployment strategy people often
see are blue-green deployments
to set up a blue-green deployment teams
need to disambiguate which services will
be consistently deployed and which
services will be shared across versions
of the application
i'll explain a little bit more of what i
mean by that in the next section
a database server would be a shared
resource multiple versions of the app
would connect to the server at the same
time
and a standard deployment would
generally not upgrade or modify the
database
in our mirn example all of the other
services are cluster resources
new versions of them would be deployed
on every prod push
so in a blue green deployment strategy
where you're upgrading the javascript
or the mirn app this is what that would
look like
so there's a blue version and a green
version of the application
where each is a fully standalone stack
but where each connects to a shared
database and the database is not part of
blue or green it's a shared resource
used by both
blue green deployments are so called
because they maintain two separate
clusters
one named blue and one named green out
of convention
if the current version of the
application is deployed to blue
we'd deploy the new version to green and
use it as a staging environment
to ensure that the new version of the
app works correctly before sending users
to it
after we're confident that the new
version of the software works correctly
we'd move over production load from blue
to green
and then repeat the cycle in the
opposite direction
so here we started with users being sent
to blue which contains version one of
the application
and then we're investigating that
version two works and after we're
certain that version two works
we'll route users to version two and
then the version one is unused and we
can shut it off and replace it with
version three
make sure it works and then switch user
traffic over to it over and over again
on the benefits side blue green
deployments are conceptually very easy
to understand
to set them up you just have to create
two identical production environments
and send requests to either one or the
other which is relatively simple with
services like amazon elastic load
balancing
they're also quite powerful longer
running tasks like downloads can
continue running in the old version
of the application after traffic is
switched over to the new version
so if a user has an established
connection to green
and you've switched everyone else over
to blue but that connection can continue
finishing whatever it was doing so if
you're watching a video and you'd like
to download it entirely to the user
which might take minutes that can
continue going even during a prod push
additionally blue green deployments can
be extended to many different workflows
which we'll discuss
there's a few notable drawbacks to blue
green deployments it's difficult to
deploy a hotfix
for example to revert a change because
the old cluster
might be running longer running tasks
and unavailable to switch to
so if you have version 1 of the
application you switch over to version 2
you realize version 2 is having problems
you might want to push a version 3 very
quickly which addresses those problems
but version 1 would be the only place
you could deploy version 3.
so you wouldn't be able to do that it's
also finicky to transfer load between
the clusters
if resources auto scale which we'll talk
about later on
and load is transferred all at once the
new cluster might not have enough
resources allocated to serve the surge
of requests
because requests went all at once to
peak production load
and finally if one cluster modifies a
shared service like adding a column to a
table in the database
it may affect the other cluster despite
it not being the live one
so here are some common extensions to
blue green deployments
as i mentioned they are very extensible
and many teams set up advanced workflows
around blue-green
deployments to improve stability and
deployment velocity
the first idea is a natural extension of
blueprint deployments which i call
rainbow deployments but i don't think
there's a standard term for them
instead of only having two clusters some
teams keep an arbitrary number of
clusters
so blue green red yellow so on
this is useful when you're running very
long running tasks
if you're working on a distributed web
scraper and your scraping tasks take
days for example
you might need your clusters to last
until the last job is finished
to ensure things continue working as
expected
so with a rainbow deployment you'd keep
all of the clusters that are still
processing
tasks around or if you're doing
something like video encoding for long
videos
you don't want to shut off the cluster
that's in the middle of encoding a long
video because that work would have to be
redone in a rainbow deployment old
clusters would only be shut off after
all
of their long-running jobs are done
processing
some teams rely heavily on manual qa and
don't use continuous deployment
they're often building desktop or mobile
apps which need to be published on
longer release cycles
so if example.com is being routed to the
blue cluster
it would be relatively simple to deploy
a new version of the application to the
green cluster
and point new.example.com to that
and with this setup the new version of
the app could be tested against the
production database
in the very environment that will soon
become production such tests are often
called acceptance tests because they're
happening in production with production
data
with nothing like no privileged access
to the code base
so for a game you might have the new
release
available or the apis for the new
release available and have your qa
testers test that
and after the qa testers give the
go-ahead you can point
the game client to the new version and
then switch the labels of the two
another useful add-on to blue green
deployments
and really deployments in general is
called the canary deployment
so if the new version of your app
contains subjective changes
such as editing the ui it might be
ill-advised to push them to all users at
once
facebook has billions of users so if
even one percent of their users complain
about a change
that would be overwhelming amounts of
feedback
the changes may break users workflows
and need to be modified or rolled back
in response to user feedback
so in the context of a blue green
deployment a canary deployment would be
to
an extension which routes maybe five
percent of user traffic to
the new version of the application and
check that those users don't have
negative feedback
before switching the rest of the users
over so if blue was version one green
was version two
we'd have ninety five percent going to
version one five percent going to
version two
we'd wait to see if anyone on version
two complained if not
then we'd route everyone to version two
and we'd shut off version one
and then put version three in that one
so blue green deployments are powerful
and extensible deployment strategy
that works well with teams that are
deploying a few times per day
the strategy only really starts being
problematic and continuous to plan with
scenarios
where there's many services being
deployed many times per day
all right let's keep talking about
deployment and i'll see you in the next
talk
[Applause]
[Music]
continuous deployment can sound daunting
but it's not actually as difficult as it
might seem in many cases
let's take a look back at our mern
example and how it's deployed
so in our readme we've
helpfully added this little line which
is how we're currently deploying to
production
if we look at our hosted version
slank which is hosted at this domain
we can see that the color is still
purple despite having changed the color
to blue
in the previous video
the reason that it's still purple is
that we haven't production pushed we
haven't pushed
the new version of the code which
contains the blue color
and oftentimes requiring human
intervention to deploy
is simply infeasible especially as
products scale
so to deploy let's run the deployment
process manually first
and then let's talk about how to
automate it with a continuous deployment
system
so here we'll use a terminal and
simply run the command directly from the
readme
this developer computer comes with the
ssh key required to deploy
otherwise it would be difficult to
disseminate this ssh key to all
developers which needed the ability to
deploy new versions of code
here we can see that it's using docker
and docker-composed rebuild
we'll talk more about how to set up a
docker file later on
and now if we refresh the page
we can see that the deployment has
created a new version of the application
which is blue so it's picked up the
color change which was merged in the
previous commit
so continuous deployment we'd like it to
run on
merges to the main branch we don't want
to deploy
feature branches before they've been
reviewed for that
we can set up a very simple
configuration
we could write this configuration file
in any directory
but let's write it in the api directory
for now
so we'll create another layer file we'll
inherit from the testing layer file to
make sure that the deployment runs after
tests have passed
and will only run the deployment if the
branch is the main branch
however if it is the main branch we'd
like to set up a secret
and use that secret for our ssh key
and then use that ssh key to run the
script
let's do that now
and it helpfully gives us the directives
we need to expose the ssh key
let's add those
so now we're exposing the ssh key which
is used to authenticate with the
production machine
within the ci process itself
one other thing we need to do is change
the ownership to be
more restrictive this is required for
ssh but it might not be required for
other deployment processes
so now that we have our ssh key within
the ci server
and these steps are running after tests
have passed
all we have to do is copy our command
and run it as if it was part of a ci
process
all this configuration does is wait for
tests to pass
check that the branch is the main branch
and then use the ssh key to deploy a new
version of the application
let's create a new pull request with
these changes and see how that looks
we can see that as before the ephemeral
environment
and ci services are being built but this
api service is also being built the api
being the directory which contains our
continuous deployment process
let's take a look at what the pipeline
actually looks like in structure
so here we can see that the application
has been built successfully
and is being started just as in our
regular ci
without cd process so we're running our
continuous integration
but not our continuous deployment step
in this layer file
and we can see the tests are running as
usual the test running process
requires starting a fake browser so this
takes around
30 seconds
and then after the tests pass we'll see
that the
deployment process runs so the tests
lead to the second level
graph these are usually called build
stages in a ci cd system
so here we can see that
the step was skipped because the branch
was not the main branch
which is exactly what we wanted however
now if we merge this pull request
we'll create a new merge branch on the
main branch and we'll run the ci process
once again
here
and because this is the main branch the
deployment process itself will be
running so let's take a look at what
that looks like
we're simply loading the environment to
run the command in right now
and here we can see that the deployment
is running within ci itself
so instead of needing to run it as an
individual developer
you can simply run this ssh command
within ci
and this idea of deploying automatically
from a ci process
is called continuous deployment
so let's work through that whole process
end to end once just to make sure that
it's
clear on the deployment automation side
of things
so let's change the color again
for the main landing page just to make
sure that
it's visible if a change gets pushed
correctly and again we'll change the two
colors
and we'll create a new pull request
and now our reviewer will have a lot of
information about
whether this change is good or not so
the reviewer will be able to see both
the file changed
so they'll see all we've done is change
a few colors
they'll be able to look at the ci
process itself
so they'll be able to see that tests are
running
so in particular that the application
builds
starts successfully tests run against it
they'll be able to look at an ephemeral
environment within minutes of me
creating this new change and
if they approve the change it'll be
shown to users in a short period of time
this whole process will only take about
a minute with the longest part being
these
automated browser tests
one by one these steps should become
green
again this is the base this is the
ephemeral environment this is the
continuous deployment process
and this is the aggregate status this is
the one that
the administrators of github might mark
as required
so that only if all of the checks pass
can the commit be merged and shown to
users so here we can see that everything
is passed
let's take a look at the ephemeral
environment just to double check that
the color
is the one we want
we can see that from the ephemeral
environment we've changed the color to
be this
rose-ish red perhaps this is the color
that was desired
so we'll say that this is correct and
the test has passed and successfully
posted a message so we know that the
functionality of the application
has continued to work after this change
after we merge it
the end to end test deploy process will
run
for this merge commit and if we take a
look at that
we'll see that because we merged to the
main branch
the deployment is already running in
production we're creating a production
build
and in a short period of time the
production server should have the latest
version of our application running
on it so here it's restarting the
production instance
and the snapshot is being taken so
everything has succeeded we've
successfully prod pushed if we go to our
website
it is now the shade of red that we've
changed and that's what an end-to-end
cicd ephemeral environment pipeline
generally looks like at a very high
level
all right so let's talk more about the
plymouth automation in the next section
[Music]
so we've talked about deployment
strategies but that's not the only thing
in deployment deployment strategies help
you reduce downtime
and deploy in a way that doesn't affect
your users
but another key consideration for
deployment is making sure that there's
enough resources
for your containers or vms so that if
there's a large burst of users
your application doesn't go down
so let's say you're building a ci system
this hits close to home because i of
course work at layer ci a ci company
your users would push code you'd have to
spin up runners
to run tests against that code and you'd
see bursts of traffic during your users
business hours
and you'd see significantly less traffic
outside of those business hours
for a peak load of 10 000 concurrent ci
runs
you'd need at least 10 000 runners
provisioned
however at night outside of peak hours
you you wouldn't really need all 10 000
runners most of them would sit idle
so your usage might look like this which
is also indicative of a lot of
applications
your lowest point is maybe 500
runners required and your highest point
is 10 000 runners required
so you need 20 times more workers
from the highest points in the day to
the lowest points in the day
in an ideal world you'd be able to
create or destroy these runners as
necessary
during peak hours you'd be able to
create new ones and in off-peak hours
you'd be able to destroy them
that's the idea for auto-scaling it's
only possible to create and destroy
workers because of cloud providers
at their enormous scale it's possible to
offer servers for cheap
on small one-hour leases the most
popular technology
at the time of this post or this video
is aws ec2 spot instances
which act exactly like cloud-hosted vms
but with large discounts if you
provision
them for short periods of time another
popular technology for auto scaling
is kubernetes horizontal pod auto
scaling
which sounds daunting but since many
providers provide
kubernetes out of the box you can just
assume that if you're using kubernetes
in containers
you'll get auto scaling if you configure
it correctly just to illustrate
if you're using microsoft's azure as
your cloud provider
there's resources for auto scaling vms
and for containers if you're using aws
there's again resources for vms and
containers
and if you're using google cloud there's
resources for vms
and containers auto scaling is usually
discussed
on the timeline of one hour chunks of
work if you took the concept of auto
scaling and took it to its limit
you'd get serverless define resources
that are quickly started
and use them on the timeline of
milliseconds so 1 to 100 milliseconds
for example a web server might not need
to exist at all until a visitor requests
a page
instead it could be spun up specifically
for that request
serve the page and then shut back down
that's exactly the idea for serverless
it's almost like taking
auto scaling so provisioning resources
as they're required
and doing it very quickly on very small
time intervals
serverless is primarily used for
services that are somewhat fast to start
and stateless
you wouldn't run something like a ci job
or ci run within a serverless framework
but you might run something like a web
server or notification service
auto scaling is primarily used for
services that are slower to start or
require state
you'd likely run a ci job within an
auto-scaled vm or container
and not within a serverless container as
of 2021
the distinction between the models is
becoming quite blurred
serverless containers are becoming
popular and they often run for upwards
of an hour
serverless containers act exactly like
containers but they're created and
turned off in a serverless manner so in
response to a trigger
within a few years it's likely that
serverless and auto scaling will
converge into a single unified interface
so i'm excited about that as that's
going to be the future of deployment
and that ends our discussion of auto
scaling and serverless
i'll see you in the next talk
[Music]
another key concept in deployment
automation is service discovery
a database might be at one ip address so
10.1.1.1.6
chosen arbitrarily while the web server
would be at another ip address
10.1.1.28080
and they'd have to discover each other
because the web server needs to talk to
the database and the database might have
calls to the web server
things get even more complicated as you
add more copies of your web server
or add entirely new services again let's
consider
the mirn app from elsewhere in the
academy devops series
so you have a web browser the user
themselves is visiting your website
they're connecting to your front end
and they're connecting to your backend
making api calls
and your backend is connecting to a
database
here there's three services that need to
be discovered
the browser needs to learn that
example.com corresponds to
the front end and example.com api
corresponds to the backend and the
backend
needs to learn that the database is at
10.111.1.3 for example
so the backend needs to know the ip
address and port of the database
and the browser needs to know the ip
address and port of the back end and the
front end
in the very simplest configuration
everything is manually configured
the back end and front end are at static
ips and given host names within dns
a domain name system it's the mapping of
example.com to an ip address on the
internet and the
end is configured to connect to mongodb
at a specific port
so your dns configuration this is the
cloudflare configuration page which is a
dns provider
would look like this so if the user
visits example.com
send them to this ip address and if they
visit
api.example.com send them to that ip
address
so this is all manually configured and
we've just manually put the ip addresses
in this
and then within the back end we'd read
an environment variable
which is a dictionary of key value pairs
that are
easily set when you're deploying things
so
you'd say connect to the environment
variable specifying the mongodb port
and then connect to port 27017 which is
the default mongodb port
and then when you're starting the back
end you just have to specify the ip
address that mongodb is running at
this configuration is completely fine
for simple products it's difficult to
mess up
it's relatively secure and it doesn't
overcomplicate things you can go pretty
far with a simple configuration
most products could launch an mvp
without any service discovery at all
but you'll know that you need to start
caring about complicating your service
discovery when you see one of the
following
so you need zero downtime deployments
you can't hard code things like this if
you want to do rolling deployments
because you can't easily automate where
the arrows point to you can't
automatically change the ip address if
you're doing such a simple
deployment strategy for example if you
have more than a couple micro services
it's going to get hard to remember where
they all are
and if you're deploying to several
environments like if you have a
developer environment a staging
environment
an ephemeral environment and production
environment that all have different ip
addresses
it's going to get pretty unwieldy to set
the ip addresses all over the place
so let's focus on zero downtime
deployments because they're illustrative
of the broader problem
before that though let's talk about
reverse proxies which are another
crucial system design and devops concept
the idea for a zero downtime deployment
is simple
as we've seen you start a new version of
the back end and front end
you wait till they're up and then you
shut off the old version
of the back end in front end so this
happens in both rolling and blue green
deployments
however it's difficult to update the ip
addresses in dns itself
if our rolling deployments require
changing these values
directly in dns that wouldn't work very
well for various reasons
in particular dns can take a long time
to propagate users in other countries
then the united states for example might
take days
to see the new ip address and they'd
still be trying to connect to the old
version
the solution is to add a web server that
acts as the gateway
to the front end and back end we'd be
able to change where it points to
without changing the dns configuration
itself
so web servers like these are called
reverse proxies and they're really
crucial for setting up zero downtime
deployments and for service discovery
itself
so taking our mirn app and adding this
level of complexity
the user's web browser would instead
connect to the reverse proxy
so the user would ask
the dns system where is example.com
the dns system would respond with oh
it's here
the ip address of the reverse proxy and
then the reverse proxy would take the
user's request and send it to the
appropriate
say v1 fret end or back end depending on
what the user asked to connect to
and then from there everything else
would be the same
so if you're running a deployment like a
rolling deployment
the proxy could choose which of v1 or v2
of the front end or back-end to send the
user's request to and that would just be
by changing a configuration file
and then after your deployment is done
you could turn off version 1 and the
reverse proxy could route traffic
entirely to version 2. a straightforward
approach
is to store the service ips in a hash
table
so implicitly in the process of writing
a deployment
we assumed that our reverse proxy would
be able to know the ips of the new
versions of our apps
which is exactly the statement of
service discovery
instead of needing to manually tell our
reverse proxy where the front end and
backhand live
so where is the ip address of version 2
of our back end
it would be convenient if we could
automate it when the new versions come
online
they can update the value for the key
back end and front end with their own
ips in this hash table
and then the reverse proxy could watch
for changes to the table and use that
for routing decisions
for a very concrete example which is
about as close as we're going to get to
code in this
setup videos let's look at this nginx
configuration
nginx is a very popular reverse proxy
and it's very
commonly used in large tech companies
and it lets you define where various
host names go
if you pointed example.com to the nginx
reverse proxy
again in the picture this would be nginx
the user thinks they're connecting to
your website
but they'd be sending their request to
nginx askingforexample.com
and nginx would take their example and
forward it to your actual front end
so nginx just has to learn where the ip
for your front end is
and that's what this configuration would
do so we're telling nginx directly
take this key from this file
and then use conf d which reads from a
hash table and updates a configuration
file
and then send the user there so
all you need is a key value store which
has
a key for where the front end ip is the
current front-end version
and then to run your rolling deployment
you'd start a new front-end version
check that it was alive and then you
just change the key in the hash table to
point to the new one
and then conf d would pick up that
change replace this value with the new
ip
of version two of the front end and then
reload engine x
which would change the arrow to the new
version of the front end
like this that was a lot to deal with so
let's back up a bit all you'd need to do
is update your front end to set the key
in the hash table for ips front end to
be the front ends ip
and then make your back end do the same
for the back end location
and that way when the new version of the
application starts
it would update the key in the table and
then nginx would start routing users to
the new version of the application
this is what proxy passing means in
nginx so
you see this proxy pass directive but
this is all very complicated
it's just an illustrative point of if
you were to implement this yourself
how would you do it the most common
thing used in industry is service
discovery by using dns itself
so dns we thought of before as the slow
protocol that might take days
to propagate changes across the network
but you can run dns locally
and that's the industry standard
so let's talk about dns a little bit
the idea for dns is just to map
hostnames to ips
when you visit lyrici.com for example
the global dns system will first map the
name layerci.com to the addresses
at the time of this video 104.21
79.86 and 172.67.169.106
which are just arbitrary computers
connected to the internet
and you can use the dig command on a
website to see where those
addresses are so this is saying for the
key layerci.com the values are these two
and usually when people mention dns they
mean the global service
so visiting websites on the internet
however as i mentioned it's possible to
run dns internally
it would be ideal if in our nginx
configuration
we could specify http full colon slash
frontend and then have frontend resolve
to the ip of our frontend service
that way we wouldn't have to change
anything except for the dns
configuration
that's exactly how dns based service
discovery works
you configure your services to query a
server you control
for dns queries and then
this so instead of saying mongodb full
colon slash
process n of mongodb you just say
mongodb full colon [ __ ] where [ __ ] is
a key
in the key value pairs in the dns that
you control
of course it's not trivial to deploy
your own dns server in practice
though there are popular options like
core dns
the most likely thing you do is use a
cloud provider or kubernetes internal
solutions
so the end result you'd get is something
like this
the user's web browser would connect to
nginx
thinking it was the website nginx would
ask
the dns provider where is
the api right now the cloud provider
would respond with
this is the ip address given the
deployment so blue green or rolling
deployment
this is what we currently want users to
visit when they want to visit the api
and then this would correspond to
version one or version two of the
backend
and then the proxy would forward the
request there the request would be
fulfilled and it would go back to the
proxy and then back to the user
so the conclusion of all of this is that
service discovery is tricky but vitally
important
as a foundational building block for
these deployment strategies and for
deployment automation in general if you
configure service discovery in an
appropriate manner for your deployments
so dns based in a kubernetes cluster for
example
it makes significantly easier for
developers to have microservices that
talk to each other
instead of having a developer have to
write connect to mongodb at
and then deal with where mongodb
actually is they can simply say
connect the mongodb at mongodb vocolon
[ __ ] and then you as the devops
platform engineer
can configure where that [ __ ] always
points to the right place the right ip
address
by decoupling the application logic from
the deployment logic
you'll help the developers on your team
build faster and you'll be able to
deploy more easily
so that's it for deployment let's go on
to the next
and final pillar which is application
performance management
there aren't that many general topics in
application performance management
so this section will be a little bit
shorter we'll go into more detail in
future sections
in the devops academy but just for this
introductory video series
let's talk about two core concepts the
first of which is log aggregation
and it's a way of collecting and tagging
application logs from many different
services
and to a single dashboard that can
easily be searched
one of the first systems that have to be
built out in an application performance
management system
is log aggregation just as a reminder
application performance management is
the part of the devops lifecycle where
things have been
built and deployed and you need to make
sure that they're continuously working
so they have enough resources allocated
to them and
errors aren't being shown to users
in most production deployments there are
many related events that emit logs
across services
at google a single search might hit five
different services
before being returned to the user if you
got unexpected search results
that might mean a logic problem in any
of the five services
and log aggregation helps companies like
google diagnose problems in production
they've built a single dashboard where
they can map every request to unique id
so if you search something your search
will get a unique id
and then every time that search is
passing through a different service
that service will connect that id to
what they're currently doing
this is the essence of a good log
aggregation platform
efficiently collect logs from everywhere
that emits them and make them easily
searchable in the case of a fault
again this is our mirn app the user's
web browser connects to a backend and a
frontend
and the backend then connects to a
database
if the user told us the page turned all
white
and printed an error message we would be
hard-pressed to diagnose the problem
with our current stack
the user would need to manually send us
the error and we'd need to match it with
relevant logs in the other three
services
let's take a look at elk a popular open
source log aggregation stack named after
its three components
elasticsearch logstash and kibana
if we installed it in our mirn app we'd
get three new services
so the user's web browser again would
connect to our front-end and back-end
the back-end would connect to [ __ ] and
all of these services
the browser the front-end the back-end
and [ __ ] would all send logs to
log-stash
and then the way that these three
components work
the components of elk elasticsearch
logsdash and kibana
is that all of the other services send
logs to logstash
logstash takes these logs which are text
emitted by the application
for example the the web browser when you
visit
a web page the web page might log this
visitor
access this page at this time and that's
an example of a log message
those logs would be sent to logstash
which would extract things from them so
for that log message
user did thing at time it would extract
the time
and extract the message and extract the
user and include those all as tags
so the message would be an object of
tags and message so that you could
search them easily you could say
find all of the requests made by a
specific user
the logstash doesn't store things itself
it stores things in elasticsearch
which is a efficient database for
querying text
and elasticsearch exposes the results as
kibana
and kibana is a web server that connects
to
elasticsearch and allows administrators
as the devops person
or other people on your team the on-call
engineer to
view the logs in production whenever
there's a major fault
so you as the administrator would
connect to kibana kibana would query
elasticsearch for logs matching whatever
you wanted you could say
hey gabana in the search bar i want to
find
errors and kibana would say
elasticsearch find
the messages which contain the string
error and then elasticsearch would
return results that had been populated
by logstash
and logstash would have been sent those
results from all of the other services
if you visited a webpage this might be
the sort of log
that is emitted and it might be
processed into an object like this
so it has a formatted date and a simple
time format that's the same for all
messages emitted by all different
services you'd have a service
which service submitted the log and
you'd have the message
the actual content of the log
and the processor logstash itself would
often be connected to the internet so
that javascript in the browser
can catch errors and send them to
logstash although there are additional
services like sentry that
might be better suited for that how
would we use elk to diagnose a
production problem
well let's say a user says i saw error
code one two three four five six seven
when i tried to do this with elk setup
we'd have to go to kibana enter one two
three four five six seven in the search
bar
press enter and then that would show us
the logs
that corresponded to that and one of the
logs might say
internal server error returning one two
three four five six seven
and we'd see that the service that
emitted that log was backend
and we'd see what time that log was
emitted at so we could go to the
time in that log and we could look at
the messages above and below it
in the back end and then we could see a
better picture of what happened for the
user's request
and we'd be able to repeat this process
going to other services until we found
what actually caused the problem for the
user
the final piece of the puzzle is
ensuring that logs are only visible to
administrators
as logs can contain sensitive
information like tokens it's important
that only authenticated users can access
them
you wouldn't want to expose kibana to
the internet without
some way of authenticating my favorite
way of doing this is to add a reverse
proxy like nginx
again our friend nginx and then have the
auth request mechanism check that the
user is logged in
so in our backend we could add something
like this
which simply returns a successful status
if the user visits
example.com authrequest and they're an
admin
it would return a successful status and
if they're not admin it would return
an unauthorized status and then we could
configure nginx
again as mentioned in previous videos to
have these location blocks
the slash private location would connect
to slash auth
and then we could make sure that
if this was logs for example that the
user was logged in
because with this auth request directive
if the user visits
logs and they're not an administrator
they wouldn't be able to access them
alternatively elasticsearch itself is
run by a company called elastic
and they have a paid version which
contains something called xpak
which facilitates this as well so you
can go for either a reverse proxy which
authenticates users
or the paid version of the application
as an aside you can use log aggregation
as an extra test
so in your ci pipelines where you want
to tell if code is good or not
you can repurpose your log aggregation
stack to ensure that no warnings or
errors occur while the tests run
if your end to end test looks like this
so you're
starting your stack you're starting your
logging stack
you're running your tests with npm run
test
you could add an extra step which
queries elasticsearch for logs matching
error and you could make sure that there
are no logs
that printed error and then even if all
of your tests pass
if there's an error going on that error
might be important despite all the tests
passing
so this adds a free extra check to your
ci stack
and there's a few examples of log
aggregation platforms there's
elasticsearch logsdash cabana which we
talked about there's fluentd
is another popular open source choice
there's datadog
which is a very commonly used at larger
enterprises
it's a hosted offering and there's log
dna which is
another hosted offering and those cloud
providers also provide logging
facilities like aws cloudwatch logs
so log aggregation is a key tool for
diagnosing problems in production
it's relatively simple to install a
turnkey solution like elk or cloudwatch
and it makes diagnosing and triaging
problems in production significantly
easier
that's it for log aggregation i'll see
you in the next talk
[Music]
the last topic we're going to talk about
is metric aggregation
metrics are simply data points that tell
you how healthy production is
so as you can see on the screen things
like cpu usage
memory usage disk i o file system
fullness
are all important production metrics
that you might care about if log
aggregation is the first tool to set up
for production monitoring
metrics monitoring would be the second
they're both indispensable for finding
production faults and debugging
performance and stability problems
log aggregation primarily deals with
text logs or textual
of course in contrast metric aggregation
deals with numbers how long did
something take
is memory being used it's frighteningly
difficult to understand what's going on
in a production system
netflix for example measures 2.5 billion
different time series
to monitor the health of their
production deployments
success for metric monitoring is being
able to automatically notify the
necessary teams when something goes
wrong in production
let's keep looking at open source
implementations of devops tools to keep
things general
prometheus a tool originally deployed at
soundcloud
is one of the most popular metric
servers
and this is what it looks like similarly
structured to elk inputs are sent to the
retrieval
things like nodes would send how much
disk usage
they have to the prometheus server but
also how long services are taking elk
itself would parse
numbers out of logs and send them to
prometheus
and then prometheus figures out what to
get services from using service
discovery from the previous video
and then it takes those and it stores it
in a time series database
equivalent for numbers what
elasticsearch is for text and then
that's stored
on the prometheus server node itself
and then finally there's a front end so
other services can query
prometheus to do things one thing you
might want to do
is if there's something terribly wrong
like your website is down
you might want to connect to page duty
or email someone or send someone a text
message with twilio
the on-call engineer and tell them that
something is wrong
but you might also want to query metrics
to get a view like this one
and that's what prom ql is used for so
grafana is the view that dark view with
the graphs
and it's common way of viewing these
time series
but you can make your own and you can
make apis and there's many other front
ends that connect to prometheus
the diagram above is daunting but it's
quite similar to the architecture that
we discussed for log aggregation
frameworks
there's four key components like i
mentioned the time series database
actually stores the measurements
retrieval
the alert manager and the web ui
so the sorts of metrics we collect well
there's a lot of subjectivity about
which metrics are important based on
what your product does and what your
users are
but here's a few ideas for what you'd
store in something like prometheus
so request fulfillment times these are
very useful for understanding when
systems are getting overloaded or if a
newly pushed change has negatively
impact performance
fulfillment times are often parsed out
of logs using a regular expression for
example
or taken out of a field in a database
for a website or rest api a common
request fulfillment time would be time
to response
for websites and rest apis a common
request fulfillment time
would be time to response that way slow
web pages could be discovered and
identified in production
a related metric that is very indicative
of problems
is request counts if there's a huge
spike in requests per second
it's very likely that at least a few
production systems will have trouble
scaling
watching request counts can also be used
to detect and mitigate attacks like
denial of service attacks
which are when attackers send many
malicious requests to services in
production
the last common metric across many types
of companies is server resources
here's a few examples so the database
size and maximum database size
if you have two terabytes of disk for
your database and your 1.5 terabytes in
you might want to alert someone to
increase the amount of disk available to
the database or delete things that are
being unused
web server memory so if your web server
is taking
a lot of requests per second and doing a
lot of processing it might require more
memory
so if it runs out of memory it would
crash and your users wouldn't be able to
access your website anymore
network throughput so if you're
downloading many things or uploading
many things
you can saturate your network and that
would also cause degraded performance
and a final one is tls certificate
expiry time
so this lock in the browser that uses
pls certificates to say whether the
browser is secure or not
are used all over the place internally
and these cause problems if they're not
measured and they're not alerted for
so for example google voice had an
outage in 2021
google of all companies wasn't measuring
when their tls certificates would expire
and that caused an outage a few months
ago
so production faults very rarely look
like no users can access anything
they're often a gradual ramp certain api
is taking longer and longer
and then eventually everything breaks
quartile analysis is an easy way to pare
down production
time statistics into something
actionable a website might measure how
long it takes for websites to fully load
their landing page
to notice when there's a very obvious
production issue so with quartile
analysis you'd split request times into
many different buckets
how long did the slowest one percent of
users take
how long did the slowest five percent of
users take how long did the slowest 25
of users take so if your landing page is
slower when users are logged in then
logged out
just by visiting without a logged in
user you might not notice
that the web page is very slow but users
that are logged in
would show up in the one percent of
requests bucket and you'd see that those
users are having a bad
degraded experience for one example
stackoverflow.com itself was notified of
an outage because their landing page was
taking a long time to respond to
requests
due to a specific post that was
published to stack overflow
for metrics analysis there's many common
production tools
there's prometheus and grafana as we
mentioned there's datadog again
not only log aggregation but metrics
aggregation as well
there's new relic which is i would say
maybe the old reliable option
and there's again a cloud providers
provide their own versions of this
there's aws cloud watch metrics
google cloud monitoring and azure
monitor metrics
that's it for application performance
management thanks for watching
[Music]
you